this video is sponsored by morningbrew
use the link in the description to sign
up for their completely free business
tech and finance newsletter
what do you think happens when we die
what
hm
didn't you just say something no sorry
what were you saying i was just asking
about how looking at colleges and
everything was going for you are you
okay do you want me to drive yeah i know
i'm fine but yeah it's been going good
actually i've looked at about several
other different schools
it was earnest and arcadia's first trip
anywhere together a short trip about two
and a half hours north to arcadia's
family cabin it was the dead of winter
so no one in arcadia's family was using
it and it was the perfect free getaway
spot for just the two of them both
earnest and arcadia had just recently
turned 18 and they were both
experiencing that early shedding of the
skin that occurs in the later portion of
youth followed by the onset of a new
form of life scaled by greater personal
freedom responsibility maturity and
uncertainty
the two were journeying into adulthood
together and feeling a connection they
had never felt with anyone or anything
before
a comfort and warmth that made it feel
like everything was going to be okay
even if it wasn't
for the first time they were falling in
love
as they got closer and closer to the
cabin their surroundings became more and
more desolate as the frequency of exit
ramps into populated towns and cities
decreased with each increasing mile into
the countryside the light snowfall
appeared to increase simultaneously as
the sky darkened and the road was
illuminated only by the car's headlights
throughout the drive the two joked and
talked about all sorts of things mostly
rudimentary normal stuff the day-to-day
of their lives school parents friends
movies sports and their future plans
before they knew it they arrived a small
but quaint cabin consumed by dark woods
in an area mostly vacant this time of
year ernest pulled into the driveway and
parked the two unloaded their bags and
arcadia unlocked the cabin door
once inside they turned everything on
turned up the heat and settled in
this place is sort of like an oasis in
the middle of nothing huh ernest said as
he organized some stuff in the kitchen
yeah it always felt like an escape when
i was a kid like everything was okay
here arcadia responded yeah it's like
somehow both unsettling and comfortable
at the same time i like it though
ernest pulled out a bottle of vodka that
he had gotten from one of his friend's
older brothers and poured two glasses
mixing the liquor with some juice he had
also brought the two sat in the living
room drinking and talking all night
about the same sorts of stuff they
talked about on the drive normalcy of
day-to-day life and school and pop
culture about anecdotes of their pasts
and plans for the future
they laughed and cried and had an
incredible time several hours later
after several drinks arcadia passed out
on the couch ernest was still wide awake
though and so he carefully carried
arcadia into the bedroom made sure she
was okay and then went back into the
living room to watch some tv and
continue to drink by himself
he watched whatever was on late night
basic cable the news then a sports talk
show then a reality show rerun then a
documentary about chimpanzees in one
scene of the documentary it showed how
sometimes male chimpanzees eat other
chimps sometimes even infants in order
to gain territory and breeding
opportunities
something about the sequence of
everything he was watching the unnerving
similarity between some of the scenes in
the news and reality show and some of
the scenes in the nature documentary
suddenly gave ernest a weird feeling in
the pit of his stomach it all made him
think about how he was a living thing in
the world and all the absurdity he was
watching on tv he was also a part of
this then made ernest think about how
all these shows how basically everything
in ordinary life was just a distraction
or neat repackaging of what lied behind
underneath and inside it a meaningless
chaos of absurdity and conflict and
violence and death what's the point of
all this ernest wondered to himself with
an increasing fervency of anxiety he
felt as if a spotlight was suddenly
being shined on some void inside him
compelled by this intense urine for
something he couldn't quite locate
ernest got up
left the cabin and walked out into the
woods
he made his way through a small lining
of dead trees as snow fell down onto his
exposed skin
fairly quickly he reached a large pond
completely frozen over he walked out
onto it he kept walking until the view
of everything around him was completely
clear and wide in all directions
once at the center he looked up at the
clear night sky filled with stars above
him he remembered how he was apparently
made of stuff that came from them this
then made him think about how if he kept
going all the way back tracing back all
the elements of his body and mind in
some strange way he would eventually
reach stars
but this then made him think about what
if he kept going further back what if he
followed what everything he was made of
back before the stars back before the
stuff that made the stars was stuff at
all how far back did it all really go
where did it come from why was it there
why was he here
he thought about how no one really knew
the answers to any of this
this then made him realize that if he
didn't know where the stuff he was made
of came from what did that mean about
where it was going where it would end up
what would happen when he reached the
end of himself when the next stars reach
the end of themselves when the stuff
that made the next stars reach the end
of themselves when everything reached
the end of itself
was this his only experience of
something before nothingness forever was
this the universe's only experience of
somethingness before nothingness forever
what even is nothingness what happens
when we die what happens after
everything dies
if everything ends does anything really
matter how could it suddenly an extreme
frigid pain came over ernest's entire
body it was a feeling unlike he had ever
felt before
then in a sudden shock he realized he
was partly submerged in the freezing
cold water of the pond the surface of
the ground had cracked beneath him and
he was now on the underside of it he
flailed dangerously in a panic pulling
parts of the surface down under with him
as he tried to grab a hold of the edge
after struggling for a few long seconds
he was able to pull himself back up but
now he stood on the surface soaked in
the freezing water uncontrollably
grasping for air and exposed to the cold
world around him
in a delirious panic ernest ran back to
the bank of the pond and then back to
the cabin
when he reached the cabin though it was
gone his car was gone
everything was gone there was only an
empty lot his panic became surreal he
quickly realized he had gone the wrong
way and was now at some sort of campsite
he turned around and ran back the way he
came but his body and mind were now
struggling to function and he had lost
most of his sense of orientation
after going several different directions
all he could seem to find was more dark
cold forest
as time passed ernest became
increasingly lethargic and tired he felt
a visceral intimation of his mortality
as he began to feel his body less and
less
i'm going to die
he thought to himself
i'm going to die
ernest panic soon turned to grief and
dread unsure of what to do and where to
go he sat down beside a fallen tree
huddled himself around himself and
closed his eyes
as he laid there he thought about the
cabin he thought about arcadia he
thought about the warmth and comfort of
that ordinary house heated just to room
temperature a few appliances a tv and
another human being whom he loved
he had never wanted anything so badly in
his entire life
the banal normality of everything on the
surface
as ernest's thoughts began to slow and
spread out more and more separated by
increasingly long intervals of
unconsciousness
suddenly a distorted soft voice of a
woman echoed through the woods and into
ernest's frozen ears
ernest
ernest
disoriented ernest woke back up hello
ernest follow my voice
where are you
just keep following my voice i'm right
here
i'm right here
i'm right here
in a life or death game of existential
marco polo ernest followed arcadia's
voice through the woods for 20 minutes
and then
he saw it
the warm light from the windows of the
cabin
in front the silhouette of arcadia
for that moment he forgot that he was
freezing cold
soaking wet
and going to die
the news can often get a bad rap as it
often should but following the events of
the world is not only useful from a
practical standpoint but sometimes just
staying engaged in this strange game we
are all playing can help our life be
more stimulating and interesting
this video sponsor morningbrew is a free
daily newsletter delivered to your inbox
monday through sunday that makes the
news entertaining easy and succinct
providing the value of staying informed
without all the negative side effects
morning brew works by consolidating the
most relevant news in areas related to
business tech and finance and turns it
into witty light short pieces that get
you up to speed every day in as little
as just five minutes recently morning
brew has made it easy to keep up with
significant changes in the housing stock
and crypto markets as well as the
unusual economic times we're facing
following the various efforts of the
feds to combat inflation like adjusting
interest rates and how these changes
might affect the consumer if you're
interested in keeping up with events and
changes in markets like these or a huge
variety of other topics use the link in
the description below and sign up to
morning brew today it takes just 15
seconds and is completely free with no
strings attached
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general if you enjoy
exploring philosophical contemplations
through short stories like this consider
checking out my book of collected short
stories the hidden story of every person
the link is in the description below
[Music]
you